[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
cetud choisir merci de nous retrouver
pour votre émission consacrée à vos
idées sorties tout de suite le sommaire
de ce vendredi 16 février de la danse ce
week end à versailles les meilleurs
couples français s'affronteront pour la
deuxième édition de la coupe de france
de danse sportive
une discipline qui a inspiré la célèbre
émission danse avec les stars sébastien
la bergère organisateurs de cet
événement sera avec nous pour nous en
parler
une trentaine d'artistes et près de 40
animaux une véritable ménagerie a
débarqué à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
le cirque nicolas zavatta douchez a posé
son chapiteau jusqu'au 28 février et les
vacances d'hiver commencent ce soir
quelles activités pour les plus jeunes
mais dany coquet nous empêche nous
emmènera du côté de rambouillet des
ateliers autour de l'exposition de dea
trice casadesus sont organisées jusqu'au
28 février
prêt à dégainer l'appareil photo le
château de versailles lance un concours
jusqu'au 15 mai la thématique versailles
en lumière les visiteurs sont invités à
capturer la lumière dans tous ses éclats
dans le château où ses jardins attention
le concours se déroule essentiellement
sur le réseau social
instagram pour participer il vous suffit
de suivre le compte du château de
versailles et de l'identifier sur chaque
photo sans oublier le hashtag versailles
lumière les gagnants seront conviés à
une soirée privée pourront découvrir le
domaine à la tombée de la nuit alors à
vos objectifs il est qualifié comme l'un
des dessinateurs les plus talentueux de
sa génération d'un jamin flahaut expose
actuellement à l'espace philippe noiret
des clayes sous bois d oeuvre inspirée
de l'afrique et de la mer des souvenirs
de voyage sous forme de bande dessinée
on l'écouté au micro de nicolas d'ambri
ce qui est assez frappant danser dans
sept pays d'afrique
c'est que il ya des choses qui sont
restés immuables en tout cas des choses
qui existaient encore chez nous il ya
cent ans qui ont disparu qui ont cours
trouvent dans les musées
et chez eux c'est encore bien vivants
quoi bas par exemple la culture maritime
traditionnelle avec des bateaux en bois
dans la forêt on coupe du bois on
fabrique des bateaux et puis on les
fabrique et puis on sait naviguer
autrement qu'avec un gps on sait
naviguer avec les étoiles avec le
journal observation tout ça
des choses qui ont disparu un peu chez
nous quoi
[Musique]
vous connaissez forcément cette émission
danse avec les stars mais
connaissez-vous la discipline a inspiré
à versailles ce samedi 17 février se
tiendra la coupe de france de danses
latines et standards sébastien la
bergère président du comité de danse des
yvelines et organisateur de cet
événement nous a rejoint en plateau
bonjour bonjour
alors tout d'abord quand on parle de
danse sportif de quoi parle-t-on
exactement on parle en fait de
l'évolution des danses de salon vers la
compétition donc vous retrouverez les
danses latines samba cha cha rumba paso
doble jive et dans ce temps là re la
valse anglaise valse lente tango valse
viennoise slow fox et quick step
alors vous l'avez dit c'est à dire du
sport mais c'est aussi avant tout du
spectacle c'est l'idée ou avis et c'est
ce sport spectacle un peu comme on peut
le voir dans le patinage bons jeux
olympiques ou dans d'autres disciplines
artistiques
donc tous toutes les catégories saffon
s'affrontent tous les âges il ya trois
catégories jeunes adultes et seniors
voilà alors en fait la particularité de
la coupe de france et que c'est une
épreuve qualificative pour le
championnat de france
vous aurez toutes les tranches d'âge
donc ça commence à partir de 11 ans et
jusqu'aux plus de 65 ans donc vous
l'avez dit valse samba tango c'est pas
mal de danse de couple un du coup donc
quelle est la difficulté justement de
cette discipline il faut faire attention
à être vraiment en accord avec son
partenaire toujours garder une unité
entre les deux danseurs il ya un gros
travail au niveau effectivement de la
connexion du travail à deux c'est un
sport d'équipé
en fait on peut comparer ça a pris un
peu de travail de double dans le tennis
ou du sport qui se pratique je pratique
à deux alors justement c'est sur cet
aspect là que va juger le jury alors les
juges en fait évalue les couples selon
quatre critères qui sont donc la
connexion c'est un des critères la
technique individuelle des danseurs la
chorégraphie et la présentation et la
musicalité l'utilisation qu'ils arrivent
à produire fait de la musique
par quelle est la particularité de
toutes ces danses la particularité de
toutes ces danses la différence entre la
valse le tango pour chaque dans ceux
spécifiquement fait chaque dans sa une à
une histoire être et vient d'un happy
bombe à la samba le brésil
le cha cha la rumba viennent de cuba le
pass d'espagne voilà la valse anglaise
donc le terme slow fox il ya des pays
anglo saxons donc chacune en fait
traduisent viennent d'une certaine
culture des pays et traduisent un
mouvement musical en fait aussi sont le
fruit d'une certain style de musique
donc en même temps que découvrir la
danse on découvre aussi le pays et sa
culture en fin de compte voilà après bon
fait pas forcément d'historiographie ou
d'explications voilà mais effectivement
c'est une manière différente de
découvrir de nouvelles cultures
on voyage un petit peu du coup voilà et
donc c'est la deuxième édition de cette
coupe de france de danse sportive on a
vu quelques images un de l'édition 2010
est à l'instant pourquoi proposer cette
compétition envers salle parce que nous
pensons que la ville de versailles est
le cadre idéal pour proposer ce genre de
manifestations il y en a d'autres qui
sont déjà dans d'autres communes des
yvelines où comme par exemple maisons
laffitte et en pensant que les yvelines
est un bon département pour ce genre de
spectacle et donc on le voit sur les
images aussi c'était au gymnase mont
boron déjà l'an dernier
voilà sarkozy face au mob ont donc c'est
un lieu privilégié donc l'avantagé nuage
montebourg on sait qu'il comporte un
parquet et donc comme c'est un sport qui
se déroule sur parquet c'est un gros
avantage par rapport à gymnase en plus
il est spacieux il est moderne donc que
des avantages
pendant qu'à l'issue de cette journée
les gagnants auront leur place pour les
championnats de france c'est ça l'idée
alors en fait les gagnants marqueront un
certain nombre de points qui permet
d'établir en fait un classement qui
après détermine la liste de ceux qui
participeront aux championnats de france
qui auront lieu au mois de mars et au
mois de mai au niveau de l'organisation
de cette journée alors comment à quel
moment ce qu'on peut venir c'est toute
la journée sera désigné 10 ans alors ça
commence à partir de
11h pour les éliminatoires 10h c'est
l'ouverture du des portes pour les
compétiteurs 11h les début des
compétitions et les finales se
dérouleront à partir de 20 heures
donc la partie la plus intéressante pour
le public ce sera à partir de 20 heures
merci en tout cas sébastien la bergère
est revenu sur votre plateau donc vous
l'avez entendu pour en prendre plein les
yeux rendez vous ce samedi à partir de
11h à versailles au gymnase mont boron
tous les renseignements sont disponibles
sur la page facebook du grand prix de
danse sportive merci encore et on reste
dans le spectacle mais dans un autre
domaine cette fois le cirque zavatta
douche et s'installe à lille le loisir
de saint quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 28
février
voyage exotique avec la caravane des
animaux acrobates et sans oublier bien
sûr les clowns véritable emblème du
cirque zavatta les premiers spectacles
commencent ce week end la compagnie est
arrivé cette semaine nous avons suivi
leurs installations
chameau ou à toucy boeuf décosse et
chevaux miniatures c'est une véritable
ménagerie qui a débarqué à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
arrivé cette semaine le cirque nicolas
zavatta se prépare pour les premiers
spectacles de l'année
la première date 2018 alors il faut
qu'on est un peu en place on a pris pas
mal de retard à cause de la neige cette
année pour nous le thème c'est sur le
brésil parce qu'on a une troupe du
brésil qui va nous faire un magnifique
numéro de trapèze volant numéro de
sangles
donc c'est sur le thème du brésil cette
année et surtout jours à la fiche des
grands clowns ci après avatar a obligé
d'avoir des quotas depuis huit
générations la troupe parcourt les
routes de france et d'europe
l'an dernier elle avait déjà fait escale
à saint quentin en yvelines
en plus du nouveau spectacle les
visiteurs pourront découvrir un nouveau
chapiteau
là dessus
la nouveau design des nouvelles couleurs
et oui elle est plus grand nombre
accueillir de plus de personnel que
personne que d'habitude on était à
environ 1000 places du palais jusqu'à
jusqu'à 1500 cette année et c'est un
monde de rêve vous savez aussi bien pour
les artistes quand ils font leur numéro
qu'ils apportent du rire de la joie au
public comme au public
normalement ils disent toujours qu'ils
sortent avec valéo bénévoles un
spectacle dans la pure tradition du
cirque tel qu'il a été inventé il ya 250
ans les trente artistes et leurs animaux
seront présents jusqu'au 28 février à
lille de loisirs et en cette veille de
vacances scolaires vous devez vous en
douter le rendez-vous des juniors va
vous donner des idées pour profiter de
ces deux semaines de repos mais l'union
par où cette semaine qu'on parte à
rambouillet parce que les équipes vont
tester est la créativité des plus jeunes
et d'entre-nous plusieurs ateliers sont
proposés en deux lieux la lanterne le
pôle culturel de la ville et le palais
du roi de rome le lieu classé monument
historique et ses rendez-vous tourne
autour d'une exposition même de deux
expositions c'est dans deux lieux celle
de béatrice quat'sous casa dessous
parlons une artiste française qui a une
formation de sculptrice avant tout
travailler sur le du volume notamment
avec des architectes la trahison et
christian de portzamparc et aujourd'hui
elle fait de la peinture elle fait des
installations textile en relation ou pas
avec des oeuvres anciennes et puis lt
aussi des arts graphiques voilà une
oeuvre qui est assez varié qui tourne
qu'il y assez récurrente qui peu tourné
souvent autour du thème du point voilà
donc elle travaille dans une relation
otan dont les activités sont adaptées à
l'âge des enfants
ça va de 30 minutes pour les plus jeunes
c'est à dire les 3 4 ans les ateliers
durent environ deux heures pour les 8 14
ans et les activités se déroulent là
aussi dans les deux lieux le palais du
roi de rome et la lanterne alors chaque
lui à son thème au palais du roi de rome
ce sont des peintures à dominante de
couleurs chaudes c'est ce qu'on a vu sur
les images à la lanterne c'est plutôt à
des toiles abstraites automne at-il
tonalités bleu et elles gagnent nous
explique cette fois comment se passent
les ateliers ils découvrent l'exposition
en compagnie d'un guide conférence
et ensuite sur l'eau barrages ils vont
avoir une petite pratique artistique
donc les tout petits vont simplement
prendre un petit fragment de tissu et
faire comme béatrice choisir une oeuvre
et poser leurs fragments de tissus en
relation avec la ils vont s'exercer à
faire des tout petits points sur un
petit un petit bristol et pour les plus
grands ça va bien sûr être un petit peu
plus élaboré vous utiliser des
techniques qui sont celles de l'artiste
alors ça va être de l'impression du
papier bulle ou encore de la gouache
l'idée c'est aussi de manipuler
plusieurs matières différentes comme on
peut le voir sur les images
alors les ateliers sont prévues les
mardis et mercredis des vacances de
février et les équipes vous conseille
bien sûr de réserver merci mélanie pour
ses idées donc de quoi vous occuper pour
toutes les vacances au moins jusqu'au 28
février
on passe maintenant à notre argent bas
avec un dernier rendez vous musical a
noté
depuis près de 15 ans vitalic travail
l'électro à la sauce française il met sa
patte énergique et mélodique
il se produira ce samedi 17 février sur
la scène de la merise deux trappes et je
vous propose justement de nous quitter
en musique sur un extrait de son morceau
sweet cigarette on se retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là je vous souhaite un excellent
week end et d'autres très bonnes
vacances
[Musique]
et